تابع معكم الان هذه الصور الاوليه
للانفجار الذي وقع في افغانستان في وسط
العاصمه الافغانيه كابول اذن هذه الصور
مشاهدينا لانفجار قرب مسجد وسط العاصمه
الافغانيه كابول يذكر ايضا مشاهدينا ان
هذه الانفجارات ارتفعت وتيرتها بشكل كبير
مؤخرا بعد سيطرت طالبان على الحكم وفي
معظم هذه الانفجارات تمت
الاشاره باصابع الاتهام الى تنظيم داعش
مازلنا معكم مشاهدينا اذا في متابعه هذه
الصور الاوليه الانفجار قرب مسجد وسط
العاصمه الافغانيه
حول المزيد من التفاصيل حول هذا الهجوم
اذا مشاهدين هناك معلومه ايضا بان هذا
الانفجار نقلا عن مراسله العربيه هو نتيجه
لغم ارضي
ولا يوجد حتى الان تاكيدات حول سقوط ضحايا
في هذا الانفجار وسنكون معكم في متابعه
خلال هذه النشره لتفاصيل هذا الهجوم